the American writer James Baldwin first
went to Paris in 1948 as a 24 year old
and was to stay in the city for much of
the next nine years and in France
intermittently until his death in 1987.
Baldwin had felt asphyxiated in America
his family had expectations of him that
he hated his friends were judgmental he
felt observed and intruded upon Society
was moralistic and prurient as a result
he couldn't be creative or free and had
the sense of being watched and commented
upon all the time it was like being
always at school or in prison
so Baldwin undertook that most inwardly
liberating of moves he went into Exile
from Paris it no longer mattered what
they were saying public opinion could
appear as it always should have done
parochial and absurd no one knew him in
the French Capital they'd never heard of
his family it was as if he had in a good
way died and been granted a chance of a
second unsigned life
in France he could create take risks
dress differently make unusual friends
and become himself
crucially Baldwin had no interest
whatsoever in assimilating into French
society he wasn't looking to swap one
narrow Village for another it was Exile
he was after that very particular state
in which one is free not to belong
anywhere in particular to escape all
tribes in order to be unobserved
anonymous and detached
it may not always be possible for us to
become actual Exiles but we should at
the very least strive to become internal
Exiles that is people who can behave
like visitors in their own lands no
longer bound by local idioces able to
cut themselves off from the mean and
restricted views of so-called friends or
disloyal families and to grow
indifferent to provincial competition
and grandstanding
James Baldwin and his fellow Exiles are
there to remind us just how much we long
to be free